je parle d'une nouvelle étude qui a été
publiée dans la revue science adventures
qui montre que le vaccin contre la coved
19 peu perturbé le cycle menstruel des
femmes et de nouvelles observations qui
permettent de constater aussi que ça
peut même toucher les femmes qui sont
ménopausées les gens disent que ce matin
avec la docteure diane francoeur
médecins obstétriciens et gynécologues
au chu sainte-justine docteur francoeur
bonjour bonjour même la cua merci d'être
là ce matin pour nous parler de ses
recherches cet index qui attire beaucoup
l'attention en ce moment sur le site web
de radio-canada est-ce que vous dans
votre pratique vous avez remarqué des
impacts liés au vaccin sur le cycle
menstruel des femmes
je voudrais on a remarqué beaucoup de
changements menstruel relié à tout ce
qui est autour de la colline évidemment
ce qui touche beaucoup souvent la
régularité du cycle menstruel c'est
beaucoup le scris le gain de poids et
surtout dans la première vague avec le
confinement on a vu par exemple chez les
jeunes adolescents ou prise de poids
énorme et oui on a vu beaucoup beaucoup
de jeunes filles et de jeunes femmes qui
consultaient pour démonstration et
régulière maintenant lorsque les vaccins
sont arrivés certains ont proposé que ça
pouvait avoir un impact toujours
difficile de savoir tant qu'on a pas
vraiment de la vraie science est ce que
c'est une perception est ce que c'est
une inquiétude est ce que c'est réel
est-ce que c'était une façon d'essayer
de convaincre les femmes de pau se faire
vacciner donc on essaie d'avoir le plus
de données possibles cet étudiant elle
est vraiment très intéressante parce
qu'il ya quand même 40 mille personnes
qui ont fait part au dessus et c'est
effectivement la première étude qui
regardent aussi l'impact au niveau par
exemple des personnes trans et des
femmes ménopausées et saute dans
cliniquement ces choses qu'on a vues
dans tous les bureaux de gynécologues
démonstration et régulière maintenant
avant de dire c'est le vaccin on est
certains hors de tout doute on n'en est
pas là il faudrait comparer avec un
groupe de femmes qui n'ont pas eu de
changement dans leurs menstruations et
j'espère qu'on sera capable d'avoir le
financement faire ces études là pour
avoir les brèves
assurer les femmes ou changer nos
recommandations si jamais il y avait une
inquiétude pour le pour l'instant dans
l'épaule pas facile finalement de bien
cerner si un impact direct du vaccin et
parce que vous l'avez mentionné ya
beaucoup de facteurs qui peuvent venir
perturber le cycle menstruel
tout à fait je pense qu'il est important
c'est de rassurer les femmes la commune
c'est une vraie maladie et vous savez
quand on est là colitti comme un billet
pour une autre et on sait pas si on va
gagner ou perdre et les personnes qui
vont se retrouver avec une colombe des
complications à long terme la colline
s'est produit les histoires et c'est
pour ça que je passe les gens doivent
continuer à se protéger si on à 65% ou à
peu près qu'on estime de gens qui ont eu
la bonne idée de resserrement qui ne
sont pas malades son poids à l'hôpital
c'est parce que les vaccins ça
fonctionne aussi donc faut prendre faire
la part des choses et une patte
démoniser la vaccination cela dit on a
vacciné beaucoup de gens avec plusieurs
doses on ne sait pas ce qui va arriver à
l'automne on se prépare à tout comme
pour l'habitude je voudrais aujourd'hui
au moment où on se parle même si on a
cette étude une même si eux des
changements menstruel ce n'est pas
dangereux pour les femmes ce n'est pas
une raison pour ne pas se faire vacciner
le pire qui peut arriver lorsqu'on a des
irrégularités menstruel c'est d'avoir
une grossesse qui n'était pas prévu et
savent à sa décharge et bien des plats
et on a suffisamment parlé d'accident
l'avortement dans les dernières semaines
savoir qui on voudrait pas que ça arrive
à personne donc c'est important pour les
femmes de savoir que si elles ont des
démonstrations et régulière de ne pas
s'inquiéter mais d'être plus prudente si
elles ont une méthode de contraception
qui seraient pas fiables dont vous faite
rassurante par rapport aux vaccins en
disant aux femmes il faut continuer sur
vacciner également le contre la corée 19
ne pas craindre que ces impacts là
puissent avoir des conséquences
importantes sur votre santé finalement
là de perturbations en deux segments
strahl
tout à fait et puis je pense que on veut
aussi avoir des données vous savez nous
à sainte-justine groupe de femmes
enceintes qui ont la colline qu'on suit
qu'on va arrêter là parce qu'on a pas de
financement pour la continuer pourtant
les crever n'est pas terminé on veut
avoir des données canadiennes on veut
avoir des données québécoises on veut
savoir qu'est ce qui arrive à nos femmes
du québec ici et oui il faut se
questionner puis il faut rester dans le
radar est toujours resté ouvert parce
que le service m'a dit si on n'a pas de
lien direct maintenant aujourd'hui parce
que quand même d'autres études qui ont
été publiées sur le reste il faut quand
même toujours resté suspicieux alors
quand les femmes ne rapporte quelque
chose on veux les rassurer mais par
contre faut continuer sur lui est-ce que
lorsqu'on aura plus de femmes on sera en
mesure de dévaluer d'autres impacts du
virus on l'a vu la coved c'est vraiment
les russes particulier on a vu par
exemple des problèmes gynécologiques on
n'entend pas souvent parler comme des
les ulcères au niveau de la ville des
enfants qui est quelque chose qui était
associé au virus avec l'aco vivre avec
le vaccin covin même si ce n'est pas un
virus vivants on a vu des ulcères qui
reviennent qui reviennent à chaque
candidat chaque vaccination et ça a été
ça a été rapporté et c'est quelque chose
qu'on n'arrive pas à expliquer
scientifiquement mais les faits sont là
alors il faut continuer à surveiller on
est toujours en mode de surveillance
qui surveille tout ce qui se passe sur
le terrain mais au moment où on se parle
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on peut rassurer
les femmes qu'on met très bien comme
quoi la recherche est très importante
mais données scientifiques également
extrêmement précieuse pour pouvoir
continuer de donner les meilleurs
conseils à diane francoeur et était avec
nous donc on dirait que merci beaucoup
d'auteurs francoeur je vous en prie
bonne journée une bonne journée